[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport sur tv 60,18 l'émission à ne pas
manquer si vous êtes un amoureux du
sport local c'est parti pour le sommaire
golf dans quelques instants nous aurons
avec nous antoine ros heures un grand
espoir français de sa discipline
c'est un enfant du golf de la boulie à
versailles et ils s'entraînent
régulièrement au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines interview à
suivre voile le skipper et binoy louis
burton est en bonne position pour
terminer dans le top 3 du vendée globe
il devrait arriver ce mercredi aux
sables d'olonne après son tour du monde
réaction ce magazine
football le club de conflans connaît
enfin la date de son sixième tour de
coupe de france les yvelinois joueront
ce dimanche 31 janvier contre vitry mais
les amateurs ont eu moins de dix jours
pour préparer ce choc interview à suivre
dans ce magazine de coach de l'équipe
carles prison l'actualité sportive c'est
maintenant sur tb 78
[Musique]
on va donc débuter ce magazine par du
golfe et par un coup de projecteur
antoine heureuse 9 27 ans a terminé ce
week-end 16e de l'abu dhabi hsbc
championship le golfeur qui a fait
toutes ses classes au golf de la boulie
à versailles est en train de se faire un
nom dans le monde de la petite balle
blanche nous avons la chance d'avoir
antoine heureuse nord avec nous depuis
sa chambre d'hôtel à dubaï
bonsoir antoine runner bonsoir alors on
va tout d'abord revenir sur cette 16e
place une réaction tout simplement est
ce que vous êtes satisfait de votre
performance
non je suis très satisfait c'était le
tournoi de reprise pour nous on a eu
cinq semaines d'arrêt donc c'est jamais
évident de pouvoir revenir comme ça et
tu as un tournoi avec un très très gros
plateau il y avait des très bons joueurs
il y avait plusieurs joueurs du top 10
mondial
le voilà deux ne pouvons faire un bon
teint pain comme ça pour la reprise
c'est très encourageant alors vous avez
terminé à moins 6 1 sur l'ensemble du
tournoi vous faites partie du coût des
meilleurs français sur cet événement
avec hébert et langue à ce que c'était
attendu c'est moins six attendus ceux -
6 oui et non c'est un parcours qui se
défend pour pas mal on a eu beaucoup de
vent non j'ai quand même dû produire du
bon jeu pour voilà pour ce score ça
qu'on a des semaines où on peut se bat
beaucoup plus bas et la c1 ce parcours
qui se défendent est vraiment bien donc
on ajouté j'étais content de mes deux
mais score et surtout content de la
manière dont j'ai joué
c'était vraiment à mon propre et vous
aviez des joueurs qui ceux qui ont
terminé derrière vous un mic lorenzo
vera ou victor perez sont plutôt les
têtes d'affiché françaises en ce moment
finalement vous commencé à montrer votre
le bout de votre nez ainsi jeu si je
peux dire c'est ça a bien c'était bien
fini déjà l'an dernier avec cette
victoire à dubaï encore et et non
j'essaie de de continuer sur cette
lancée et voilà cette première semaine
s'est plutôt bien passé donc très
encourageant
justement c'est cette victoire à dubaï
est ce que vous avez pu la savourer un
je le rappelle c'était en fin d'année
est ce que vous avez pu elle a savouré
trois mois après on va savourer oui j'ai
profité j'ai profité à fond parce que
c'est vrai que dans le golfe où on gagne
très rarement
c'est pas comme un sport comme le tennis
par exemple où les meilleurs gags assez
régulièrement nous c'est vraiment très
rare c'est une fois par ans et c'est
déjà énorme
donc voilà il faut savoir profiter
j'avais un autre tournant la semaine
d'après donc j'ai pas pu non plus chez
petro saab
et puis même en rentrant à paris c'est
vrai qu'avec toutes les mesures
sanitaires ça c'est compliqué aussi bien
en tout cas j'ai j'ai pu quand même
profité avec avec ma famille et quelques
amis
en rentrant c'est sympa alors c'était
votre première victoire après seulement
24 des parts c'est bien ça oui et du
coup ce sont des débuts encourageants
est ce que vous attendiez à commencer
aussi fort sur le circuit
bah je m'y attendais oui j'étais prêt je
savais que j'avais un très très bon
niveau de jeu quand je suis sortie de la
deuxième division
quand je suis arrivé je savais que dans
les bonnes semaines j'avais le niveau de
jeu pour voilà pour performer même sur
sur le grand circuit donc après c'est
jamais évident de gagner un tournoi donc
voilà j'ai réussi à faire ça dès ma
première année c'était c'était quelque
chose d'assez dingue c'est sûr que c'est
un moment qui restera gravé pendant très
longtemps dans ma mémoire parce que ce
que voilà la première victoire sur le
grand circuit c'est fait pour l'avenir
alors vous avez également été élu
meilleur rookie de cette année 2020
pareil c'est une reconnaissance de la
part de vos pairs ouais ouais non c'est
un beau titre c'est sympa c'est hyper
symbolique
maintenant c'est pas quelque chose qui
qui va entraîner mais changer quoi que
ce soit ma vie mais c'est très
symbolique ça fait toujours plaisir
d'être reconnu pour quand on a fait du
bon travail dans une dans une allée donc
voila c'était très agréable de recevoir
ce titre en fin d'année et mais voilà
c'était très symbolique et ça fait ça
fait très plaisir et le regard des
golfeurs at il changé d autres golfeurs
est-ce qu'il a changé ce regard aux noms
n'ont pas regardé tous on est assez
soudé dans le dans le clan français
on s'entend tous plutôt bien donc non
non non c'est on s'encourage tous un peu
les uns les autres donc corps y en a un
qui gagne on est tous content pour lui
et mais non le regard ne change pas
forcément
alors on veut maintenant parler de votre
rapport aux yves hinant je le disais
vous êtes un enfant du golf de la boulie
un versailles
ouais c'est ça mais j'ai vraiment grandi
là bas on peut le dire j'étais au jardin
d'enfants enfin depuis tout petit voilà
jardin d'enfants à la boulie je faisais
du hockey sur gazon à la boulie quand
j'étais quand j'étais plus jeune
et puis voilà j'ai persisté dans dans le
golfe et voilà j'ai toute ma famille qui
est qui à la bouille et ouais on peut
dire vraiment que le j'ai grandi là bas
c'est un très très bel endroit pour
rebondir et vous allez taper vos
premières balles vers 3-4 ans était à la
boulie également ouais c'est ça c'est ça
c'est ça il y avait j'avais mes
grands-parents qui est qui était donc
membre des ja de la pluie il mes parents
s'y sont mis aussi
et voilà ça s'est fait assez
naturellement ils m'ont mis depuis
depuis tout jeune
dès que j'ai pu tenir un club en main
j'étais à l'école de golf à la pluie est
ce que c'est un golf où on peut se
perfectionner pour attendre vous livrer
complètement c c'est je pense le golf en
france où on peut on a entre guillemets
il ya un vrai projet sportif dans ce
club il ya des infrastructures qui sont
vraiment excellentes pour pour
l'entraînement et pour
perfectionner son jeu donc je crois que
c'est vraiment pour moi et je sais pas
c'est sans être chauvin mais c'est je
crois que c'est vraiment le golfe où on
peut on peut vraiment dire c'est que
s'extasier s'entraîner lors de très
bonnes conditions
il ya d'autres pépites un également
qu'ils sont en sortie de ce golf je
pense notamment à malange italie
inquiets sur le tour le tour féminin
est-ce que vous la connaissez bien et
est ce qui est effectivement elle peut
également aller aller très haut bien sûr
dans avec maintenant on se connaît bien
on a le même âge on en a trouvé plein de
compétition en équilibre on était plus
jeunes
voilà on a grandi ensemble on est très
amis dans la vie aussi donc ouais je te
souhaite plein de bonnes choses sur les
circuit féminin et et puis je suis
convaincu que tout va aller dans le bon
sens pour elle est très rapidement alors
vous était également vous entraîner
également au golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines
en parallèle ouais ouais je vais j'y
vais assez régulièrement c'est vrai que
le parcours est laid il est de très
bonne qualité il est très exigeant il
est dur donc voilà pouvoir s'entraîner
là-bas
quasiment toutes les semaines c'est un
vrai plus pour pour moi et voilà c'est
un parcours qui est aussi dans de très
bonnes conditions et c'est aussi le
parcours de l'open de france donc voilà
devoir s'entraîner là-bas
le jour où je jouerai cet open de france
ce sera peut-être un plus un plus pour
moi de pouvoir m'entraîner là bas on va
revenir à vos ambitions pour cette année
à 2021
quelles sont-elles plus de victoires
peut-être ouais c'est de chercher un
autre titre je pense que ça c'est un bel
objectif maintenant je vais essayer de
grappiller des places au classement
mondial cela je suis chiant quatrième
c'est déjà je peux rentrer dans les 100
ça pourrait même ouvrir certaines portes
pour voilà jouer des plus plus gros
tournoi des tournois du grand chelem par
exemple donc
donc là dans un premier temps voilà
essaie de passer c'est cette petite
étape du top 100 mondial
et puis voilà essayer de faire des
grosses perfs danser au tournoi et puis
a plu à moyen terme rentrer dans le top
50 mondial et jouer encore les des plus
gros tournois avec les meilleurs joueurs
au monde ça va être le but à moyen terme
quels sont les secteurs peut-être que
vous devez encore travailler dans votre
jeu j'ai envie de dire tout le côté
scoring google c'est à dire le petit gué
voilà et c'est de faire des approches un
peu plus proche des drapeaux c'est
vraiment là qu'on gagne des points donc
on peut toujours s'améliorer dans dans
ces compartiments du jeu donc c'est
peut-être l'endroit où il faudrait
encore s'améliorer
le pi2g tour le tour américain le plus
médiatisé est ce que ça pourrait être un
objectif à long terme pour vous
complètement quand je parlais du top 50
mondial tout à l'heure c'est c'est un
des critères pourrait m'ouvrir le
circuit américain donc lepidi et tour
j'ai vraiment là bas qu'il ya il ya les
meilleurs joueurs au monde c'est la bac
il ya le plus de points mondiaux à aller
chercher donc voilà c'est la mecque du
golf pour moi j'ai fait mes études en
université américaine voilà de pouvoir y
retourner plus tard ça serait vraiment
un bel objectif pour moi alors il ya eu
également cette ryder cup en france en
2018 au golf national de saint quentin
en yvelines
je sais que vous y étiez en a vu
d'ailleurs on a vu des photos on la voit
d'ailleurs à l'écran ce moment est-ce
que c'est aussi un objectif forcément de
carrière une ryder cup
forcément c'est vrai que comme je disais
je
j'ai fait du hockey sur gazon g j adore
ce qui est compétition par équipes donc
la ryder cup c'est quelque chose qui
fait vraiment rêver et puis si on est
sélectionné dans cette équipe ça veut
dire que quand on a fait de très gros
résultat à côté aussi donc non pour moi
c'est vraiment un rêve de pouvoir jouer
cette compet j'étais à la ryder cup à
paris tous les jours
j'y suis allé tous les jours deux
dès l'ouverture des portes jusqu'à la
fin de la journée donc voilà j'ai passé
une semaine de dengue là bas donc ça a
donné ça donne envie forcément on voit
ça paraît si lointain maintenant de voir
tout ce public mais mais c'était
vraiment un très très bon moment et je
pouvais faire un jour partir de partie
de cette équipe ce serait un truc de
dingue
dernière question en france il y aura
également en 2024 les jeux olympiques
avec le golf national notamment qui
accueillera les épreuves les épreuves de
golf est-ce que c'est également dans un
coin de votre tête
ce sera ma dernière question est
forcément
forcément je suis un dingue de 1,22
sport en général tous sports confondus
donc jouer les jo c'est vraiment un rêve
là il ya tokyo qui arrive j'espère
pouvoir me qualifier
c'est vraiment un rêve là de gosse a vu
que je suis un passionné de sport ça
serait vraiment un truc un truc énorme
pour moi donc
et puis voilà pouvoir les faire à la
maison 24 ce sera encore plus beau donc
forcément ça va être un vrai objectif
merci beaucoup antoine ros honneur pour
cette interview depuis à dubaï un je le
rappelle on vous laisse dormir on
continuera en tout cas vous suivre à
suivre vos performances sur tv 78 merci
beaucoup
à bientôt un mot de voile à présent le
skipper louis burton 1 réalisent
peut-être l'exploit de ce vendée globe
le sportif originaire de rambouillet 11e
il y à un mois fait désormais partie
d'un trio de tête avec charlie dalin et
boris herrmann
l'un de ces trois hommes devraient
remporter la victoire mercredi prochain
date prévue de leur arrivée au dernier
pointage l'yvelinois est actuellement
deuxième du classement après +2 97% de
course effectuée il a effectué la
journée de dimanche en tête de la régate
une situation qui n'a pas l'air de
perturber louis burton navigateur ouvert
l'une de ces à dernière conserve
hier dans la journée pour se faire une
salade il a également enregistré cette
vidéo il explique son ressenti sur ces
derniers jours de course
regardez
prévient on croise pas mal de marques de
bateaux le jura
la civilisation approche
et puis
poissons volants sur le plus
l inca dû réussir à se cacher quelques
pardon
ja
voilà sinon bah ça c'est bien ça va vite
vous valez à leur contrôle
et
m
un vote aura là
très passionnant parce que
regatta
louis burton devrait donc arriver à ce
mercredi aux sables d'olonne on vous
fera vivre cette arrivée sur tv 78 dans
le journal mercredi soir prochain
on va maintenant ouvrir une page volley
ball on joue un match très important
ce week-end dans les yvelines dans le
championnat élite conflans andresy jouy
s'est imposé 3 sets à 0 contre marseille
volley 13 samedi soir dans leur gymnase
le score 25 à 17 28 à 26 et 26 à 24 une
bouffée d'air au classement pour le club
du 78 qui pointe désormais à la 7e place
sur 11 l'équipe engagée
le président du club philippe
montaudouin revient sur cette rencontre
on les écoute
un vrai soulagement parce que c'est un
match important au classement entre deux
équipes qui luttent pour s'échapper de
la zone de relégable donc quand on gagne
3-0 on prend trois points bas c'est déjà
une bonne opération comptable
après sur le sur le jeu en lui même
enfin les gars ont fait un vrai beau
premier set où on a retrouvé la
dynamique là quand notre équipe jouant à
100% quoi vous vraiment un beau premier
set bien maîtrisé puis après nous est
vraiment très acharnée où marseille nous
a vraiment posé des problèmes aux à
chercher le voir à coups de 26-24 dans
le deuxième 20 28 26 dans le deuxième et
26-24 donc troisième temps dark c'était
un match après qu'ils étaient très très
disputé le prochain match de conflans
andrésy jouy devrait être programmée le
week-end prochain l'extérieur contre
caudry à volley-ball une belle
performance dans l'illinois en tennis
également arthur rinderknecht originaire
de saint germain en laye est allé
chercher son troisième titre sur le
circuit challenger le français de 25 ans
s'est imposé en finale du tournoi
d'istanbul face à un autre français
benjamin bonzi le match a été remporté
en trois sets 4-6 7-6 7-6 le tennisman
du 78 tu vas faire une progression au
classement mondial il va pointer à la
134e place dès cette semaine du football
à présent le sait depuis à la semaine
dernière le ministère des sports
autorisés les clubs amateurs engagés à
jouer la coupe de france de football
malgré la pandémie dans les yvelines un
seul club est encore en concerner le
club
de conflans jouera ce dimanche à 4
heures contre vitry son sixième tour de
coupe de france et deux clubs évoluent
en r1 les événements donc un peu moins
de dix jours pour préparer cette
échéance très importante pour le club un
calendrier loin de faire l'unanimité on
écoute l'entraîneur de l'équipe seniors
car la prison étaient menées coûte que
coûte au détriment des joueurs amateurs
parce que en fait déjà parler
d'intégrité physique et morale
quand je dis d'intégrité morale c'est
parce que finalement l'intégrité
physique déjà sera mise à mal on va
avoir la classe on aura des blessés
c'est sur un match à sa part au match de
cette importance se prépare un mois et
demi quand on n'a pas joué depuis trois
mois les joueurs devront fournir un test
pcr négatif effectué moins de 72 heures
avant le match le jour du match les
joueurs devront effectuer un test
antigénique en cyclisme sur piste une
légende a décidé de tirer sa révérence
en ce mois de janvier
grégory baugé a annoncé sa retraite
sportive le pistard originaire de
maisons laffitte et de montée sont
notamment remporté neuf titres de
champion du monde on ne le verra donc
plus au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines comme sportif
de haut niveau
un seul regret dans son immense carrière
le titre olympique qui n'a pas réussi à
remporter l'or il a quand même glané
trois médailles d'argent et une médaille
de bronze
nous avons réussi à le joindre par
téléphone il nous donne son sentiment
par rapport à ce rendez vous manqué avec
les jo on écoute ce que je me suis fixé
j'ai toujours et champion olympique
forcément ça c'est mon fils sur tf1
signe basque il vient aussi des faux tu
peux se fait-il que tu t'y fais est de
paralyser le son du score de son de
direction à présent un poids si le
journaliste sportif pierre ménès c'était
ce jeudi au centre de vaccination chez
maurice est le maire de la commune karl
olive l'a accueilli à cette occasion
carmenes fait partie des personnes à
risque puisqu'il a subi deux greffes
rhin et fois ces dernières années et a
donc décidé de recevoir la première
injection dès aujourd'hui avant rappelle
dans quinze jours en écoute les
réactions micro de tv 78
jaffe le pragmatique dans la vie on a
pleuré pour avoir des masques quand il y
avait des masques
on voulait pas en mettre on a pleuré
pour avoir des vaccins aujourd'hui on
voit que quasiment la moitié des
français un petit peu moins heureusement
aujourd'hui qui sont contre moi je
trouve que voilà si on veut revivre
normalement qu'on veut que le pays
reparte normalement il faut qu'on soit
un maximum
vacciner le plus vite possible je crois
à la force de l'image je crois à la
force de l'exemplarité et toutes celles
et ceux qui modestement peuvent inciter
encore une population qui est indécise à
se faire vacciner
elles en sont convaincus elles
deviennent convaincante on termine par
de la marche à pied la 86e édition de
paris mantes qui devait se dérouler ce
week-end a été annulé mais les
organisateurs ont décidé de créer un
défi le principe ce week-end les
participants sont invités à parcourir un
total de dix mille kilomètres en deux
jours en cumulant leurs marches
individuel les marcheurs pourront
enregistrer leurs performances grâce à
un dispositif gps ils pourront effectuer
12 22 39 et 54 km toutes les
informations sont sur le site internet
du paris mantes si le défi est relevé un
chèque de 1500 euros sera envoyée à
l'association menthe solidarité c'est la
fin de cette émission merci d'avoir
suivi à bientôt sur tv 78 très belle
soirée
[Musique]
m